all right everybody here we are again
Donald Trump scheduled to have a
coronavirus press briefing at the bottom
of the hour but there is news going on
and Donald Trump just recently held
another event I'm going to play a clip
for you where Donald Trump said oh why
are we at 12 new members by the way I'm
starting in the wrong spot Donald Trump
said he will be deploying these
paramilitaries to an additional city the
city of Chicago Illinois
why Chicago I wonder wow I can't imagine
why so the exact authoritarian
prediction that I made Friday and then
Monday and then Tuesday and again today
it's happening it's happening and this
was a trial balloon in Portland Oregon
it is now happening in Chicago this is a
vicious cycle
okay I'm gonna explain what I mean by
that in a moment but let's take a look
at what Trump said just minutes ago Bri
American no matter their income their
race or their zip code should be able to
walk their city streets free from
violence and free from fear for this
reason today I am announcing that the
Department of Justice will immediately
surge federal law enforcement to the
city of Chicago the FBI ATF DEA right US
Marshal Service and Homeland Security
will together be sending hundreds of
skilled law enforcement officers to
Chicago to help drive down guild law
enforcement officers what he means is
camouflaged paramilitaries dressed more
like they should be in a desert than in
a city with unmarked vans that's what
we're talking about violent crime and
murderers and violent criminals are
breaking a wide range of federal laws we
have that it's as wide as it can be we
will find them arrest them and prosecute
them so listen here's what's going on
and remember we're still waiting for the
press briefing is supposed to be about
coronavirus but no doubt there will be
questions about this and this this is
absolutely crazy
I have like two
ages of notes here just kid these are
prop notes this is a blank piece of
paper I wouldn't really do that to you
guys but here is where this is a
different no I'm kidding the notes are
digital notes but let's imagine that I
have my notes here and it's just pages
and pages of notes about you know
there's the element of this of the
legality Kaylee maghen Annie cited an
element of I believe it's 40 US Code
1315 or something like that the number
doesn't so much matter but it's very
specific in that these troops can be
deployed to States to protect federal
property and that can mean two things
buildings owned by the federal
government or like if some local company
rents a building to the federal
government and the federal government
has an office in that building that
would also count when you get across the
street or three blocks away or wherever
the authority doesn't go that far
and importantly if you actually look up
40 u.s. code 1315 you will see that it
also says if they want to go anywhere
beyond the federal property they need to
be working in concert with state and
local authorities the mayor of Portland
doesn't want them there Lori Lightfoot
the mayor of Chicago has said she
doesn't want them there so this legal
case is hanging by a thread
that's number one okay number two this
is a strategy to create chaos okay
here you might I mean I know some of you
follow this stuff and some of you don't
follow it as much how is this useful to
trump getting reelected right that's the
question that a lot of people are
wondering here's the way it works Donald
Trump wants to make the case that he's
for law and order and Joe Biden is not
that Joe is for abolishing the police
Joe Biden is not in fact there's people
on the Left who wish Biden were for
abolishing the police and they're mad
that Biden is not for abolishing the
police okay so Trump's idea is I am
going to loudly talk about how the crime
is out of control in quote liberal
Democrat cities
I'm going to send in troops so what am i
doing I'm saying you're gonna get more
of this crime if Joe Biden is elected
but I'm the law and order guy now it's
going to have a secondary effect which
is the presence of these troops creates
more escalations which further allows
Trump to justify deploying more troops
and keeping them there up to and
including through election day to
intimidate voters incite his own
followers pretext for questioning the
you know the how much you can trust the
results of the election so that's the
idea here okay
and of course starts with Portland
expands to Chicago and we're going to
see it expand further if we saw well not
Trump but if other presidents if Obama
had seen other countries doing this he
would have called it out if George W
Bush had seen other countries doing this
he would have called it out our
president it's not just that Trump isn't
calling it out he's doing it he's doing
the thing which is absolutely
unconscionable and it is the sort of
circular firing squad of sorts and using
chaos to generate chaos etc so we'll see
how much Donald Trump talks about this
momentarily now in the meantime
coronavirus is out of control
yesterday for the first time since June
2nd I believe let me look so yesterday
we had 1100 19 deaths you have to go
back to June 2nd to find a day with more
deaths than yesterday ok so the idea
that we're merely putting out embers now
we've basically won no that's that's not
the case whatsoever the numbers so far
today let's just refresh real quick we
are up to a 48 thousand new cases today
and again 833 deaths and as you can see
here many states have not even reported
yet a bunch of these states are blanks
so we may once again be there now you
might have noticed that yesterday when I
covered Donald Trump's first new era
coronavirus press briefing he was a sort
of totally different Trump you might
remember that he said it could get worse
before it gets better that's not
something Trump has ever said he's been
you know we have 15 cases and it'll soon
be zero that's been Trump's approach
yesterday Trump said I'm all about masks
masks masks masks that would have been a
logical press conference on March 12th
and clearly somebody got to Trump we
know Trump recently got rid of Brad Parr
scale as his campaign manager and
brought in Bill Stepien one of the guys
I think involved in the Bridgegate
Fiasco in New Jersey and it's possible
that Bill Stepien said listen I'll do
this but you've got to listen to me you
might notice that as of earlier today
Trump hadn't even tweeted let's see wait
Twitter real Donald Trump let's see
where he was okay so now he's kicking it
back up but he went all day other than
publishing his own clips from recently
as you can see here he published that oh
okay and so he had this one tweet today
so Trump only tweeted seven times today
and only one of them was a tweet like
this for Trump that's not very much but
but clearly this is a different Trump
and it's a Trump that's acting out of
desperation so that's what's going on as
far as that goes
what else did I want to get to before we
keep going so this is scheduled for the
bottom of the hour 5:30 p.m. Eastern
Time 2:30 p.m. Pacific and hopefully it
starts on time I mean you never know
with these things it's very very much
unpredictable I do want to thank Min
Vikings for subscribing over on Twitch
and also Christopher Robin who is now
subscribed for three months via twitch
prime very much appreciated I'm
inconsolable still the top gifter on
Twitch has gifted 400 subscriptions on
Twitch an unbelievable powerful number
we do have super chats coming in if
you're just joining me on youtube as
8000 of you currently are you can of
course hit the like button you can of
course subscribe to the channel for free
but you can communicate with me via the
super chat function those messages will
pop up in the bottom left of the screen
a few super chats that came in unknown
prodigy says more important than all
this though Dave
Kassel early to win yes you might have
seen yesterday my livestream with
Alexandra botas teaching me some chests
that'll be published to YouTube
tomorrow at I think 3 p.m. mike litoris
come on David you have begun
brainstorming ideas have you begun
brainstorming ideas for your 1 million
subscribers show what can your fans
expect so my original goal was a million
subscribers by Election Day and it
really did not seem like it was going to
happen and recently we were on target
for January 4th 1 million subscribers on
YouTube the last two weeks have been so
crazy we're on track to hit that again
in 2020 so no plans yet it's still far
away we've got so much going on daily
that I have not had time to think about
that Jacob Ratner says how do we fight
bad faith arguments from trumps feds for
trumps feds well fight them with the
facts and check I have a lot of clips on
that so I'm not going to go into the
details now but we have to we have to
understand the reality of the legality
of these paramilitaries waffles jirafa
says what could go wrong with federal
troops in more cities yeah of course
Matt Chavez says creating a false flag
operation perhaps well again the idea is
claimed that you need to send in the
troops because it's too chaotic but
sending in the troops causes more chaos
that's that's the idea Sam Dean says
g'day Dave South Australia is
threatening 2 years prison for illegal
state border crossings in new lockdown
rules $4,000 fine in Victoria ok
earthling says it's the dress rehearsal
for what we can expect if Trump loses in
November I I don't believe that that is
completely wrong I don't believe that
that's completely wrong I think there is
very much something to that Joseph
Dizzy's says hey David what's your
opinion on the fur net con cola in my
opinion I don't get the effete of the
appeal if you don't like for a net
Concorde out what drinks do you like
yeah I am more of a fan being
Argentinean of course it's almost
mandatory that I like fernette eide
like Fernet but I don't drink soda so
Fernet and coke is not my thing
I just prefer Fernet on the rocks I see
people on Twitch asking why YouTube chat
is disabled clearly it's not I'm reading
chats literally as we speak Nickelodeon
says David how can this deployment of
force to be an election strategy
almost everyone need reasonable objects
okay I I was probably explaining that
when you sent that Super chap so I won't
react splain it thank you to the mall
for subscribing with twitch Prime
beautiful things are happening on Twitch
in fact we're approaching 40,000
followers on Twitter which is exciting
very very exciting let me say a few
thank-yous
Jared ku mentis is new member number one
today at join pakman.com I appreciate
that we are now live in the room that's
a good sign
Jordan Slaton is new member number two
today at join pakman.com and peter Cates
hey Peter Peters new member number three
and I believe that that's it Oh Sam Dean
Sam Dean from Australia is new member
number four today at join pakman.com the
room slowly filling in if you're just
joining us Donald Trump announcing very
very recently that if YouTube chat is
looks disabled to you just refresh okay
Donald Trump just recently announcing
that he will be sending paramilitaries
to the city of Chicago the city of
Chicago and that's going to be it's
gonna be something Kristin Whittaker
says keep it up immanuel kant's says who
do you think will be the face of the
progressive movement when it comes to
electoral politics I've been asked that
a lot
I don't know sinful solutions solutions
says urgently smash the like button very
strongly I approve that message
Sean McCracken says police say hi to my
mother Kathy and wife rainy the whole
family loves your journalism thank you
also unmute me on Twitter okay I have no
idea about the Twitter thing I do have
probably 5,000 people muted on Twitter
that is true but I don't know anything
about Sean McCracken hey Kathy hey rainy
very much appreciate your support
Oboro 13 says ILWU local 13 in the house
Johnny Minogue hey David did you ever go
tubing down the Deerfield River when
living in Western Mass that's the best
summer activity out there you know I
have not I have not a big thank you from
Kristen Whitaker Kevin Mayer says this
is about making democratic run cities
look weak it's about making Democratic
run cities look weak and it's about
making Joe Biden look weak I see people
on twitch asking to be taking off of
taken off of shadow band but clearly
they are not band since they are sending
messages actively I love that connor's
it Trower says David what can we expect
from trunk Trump during his lame-duck
period if he is not re-elected it's
anyone's guess we can expect anything
from Trump goes into a shell and we just
don't see him during those two and a
half months all the way to widespread
deployment of paramilitaries nationally
it's it's anyone's guess quite frankly
anything could happen parity Rand has
high David and all mates watching yes
Evan says I'm in downtown Portland right
now it's a beautiful and
well-functioning City were used to
protests in the Pacific Northwest
Donna William says thanks David love
your commentary Johnny Bishop Trump
tried to start a war with North Korea
and Iran without success I never thought
he would start a war on ordinary
Americans I love the show from the UK
yes many people recognizing that Trump's
idea it's not even Trump's idea this
idea generally of a military conflict to
justify one's own re-election typically
it's deployed internationally Donald
Trump is deploying it domestically which
is quite stunning let me say thank you
to - mu P for subscribing at Tier one
over on Twitch beautiful absolutely love
that
[Music]
William Oliver says thank you for your
help getting through this crappy year I
can always count on you for excellent
points thank you
fanatic says what will be the state of
Republican politics post Trump so I have
a story today on my youtube hold on let
me pull up YouTube I accidentally pulled
up my only fans but I'm trying to pull
up YouTube the story is called the
future of the America the joke by the
way
the future of the American right and I
address I take about 15 minutes and talk
about exactly that issue that clip is
publishing actually in four minutes
so I'm addressing that momentarily by
the way I don't actually have an only
fans people asked me to make one but I
have a cameo instead and I'm getting a
bunch of requests on there how many
requests have I gotten on cameo let me
see
I actually have to turn some down
because they're inappropriate 49 okay so
I've gotten 49 requests on cameo yeah
I've turned down I think it's like three
or four because they were things I
looked up and they're like you know
white supremacist code or stupid stuff
where I know someone wants to take it
out of context stuff I don't even know
it's just I'm not do anything like that
I'm not doing and it's just not come on
you know let's let's let's try to be
adults and I oh not everybody in the
chat are adults that's okay but let's at
least behave like adults very powerful
hundred dollars super chat from Jacob
ball Jacob has been around for a long
time and is a great supporter hey Jacob
I for one am shocked that our leftist
friends like Tim Poole are for this I
thought the First Amendment was what
gave them no choice but to defend the
right because they were so principled
about it being violated by private
corporations First Amendment doesn't
apply to our government I guess I don't
know what Tim Poole has been saying
quite frankly so I would not be able to
comment on that but it is certainly an
interesting comment okay Daniel Banja or
Benicia as we would say in Argentina
says in Spanish where this outside of
the video and knew better than mu that
Sarah - yes so what Daniel has asked
for is for me to pause rather than mute
the video when I want to interject we've
gone back and forth about this many
times and the consensus was that we
would fall so far behind live if we do
that
that people weren't liking the idea but
you know that's certainly something that
could be could be could be explored let
me say thank you to Olivia and Gabe
Cordova for signing up at join
pakman.com they are I guess together new
members number 5 sounds weird to say new
new member even though there's two of
them but you know what can you do I will
just extremely briefly
I've been we've been doing so these like
ninety two hundred and twenty minute
streams I'm taking one minute to talk
about membership and then not mentioning
it again and it's going really really
well our program where we do an hour
podcast and the YouTube clips will take
live calls once a week anywhere from one
to three streams a day yesterday we had
three streams it's all mostly funded by
website memberships at join pakman.com
there's all these different things you
can sign up for twitch and YouTube and
all this stuff the most important
revenue source for us is website
membership anybody who signs up during
the stream I'll give you a beautiful
thank you and shout out we have a coupon
code they're 2020 now which is a great
savings but this month we have an
unpublished coupon code July's surprise
okay now that's all lowercase that's the
little letters no spaces July surprise
this thing Kim jong-un would kill family
members for less than a coupon code this
significant I know that that's harsh but
it's this this is a crazy coupon code
and we are sort of trying to dig out
from a lot of people who have
unfortunately had to cancel because of
the virus and I get what's going on a
lot of people financial instability
people are canceling I don't take it
personally it's okay but if you are
someone who can throw a dollar 80 a
month or 2 bucks a month at a membership
at join pakman.com please do and you get
a bunch of great perks and I will thank
you that
the most important thing like for
example Who am I going to think Michael
quintanilla who is new member number six
today at join pakman.com okay let's
continue with some of these super chats
coming in actually first let me say
thanks to door vana 1967 and Jo in a box
for subscribing over on Twitch dr. rain
says this phony trump won't last there
is no way you can hold this pattern of
miniscule morality for very long and
even if he could it's too damn late
that's my view that's my view Kevin
Ganser says what activities are keeping
you busy during the pandemic gardening
you should see my zucchinis I bought a
zucchini plant that was essentially
three leaves that are Sharpie sized okay
bought it planted the thing it has taken
over I have about 25 zucchinis that now
are growing one of them is at least 10
inches and I should do another garden
tour maybe I'll do that if we we have a
goal of 25 maybe if we get to 50 members
right after this is done I'll go out and
film a new garden tour my cukes are out
of control you should my cucumbers are
like nothing I've ever seen before
to me I've got 75 or 80 tomatoes that
are in the ripening process mint has
completely - I know mint is invasive so
I have mint in its own pot it's
completely taken over it's outrageous
what my mint is doing and yes soon I'm
going to be powerfully harvesting some
of these zucchinis it's it's outrageous
outrageous I've never seen zucchini do
this and then you know biking running
I'm in this pogchamp stew chess
tournament on chess calm next month so
I've been training from the standpoint
of chess as well okay if you're just
joining us by the way we are standing by
for Donald Trump's press
briefings scheduled for two minutes ago
Donald Trump about an hour ago
announcing he is going to be deploying
these federal paramilitaries to the city
of Chicago exactly as I predicted
yesterday and the day before and last
Friday that's happening I anticipate
some questions about that if you are
just joining us on YouTube please
consider pressing the like button not a
big ask and pressing the subscribe
button
we shockingly I don't even know how this
happened
we're only 9000 subscribers away from
900,000 which is just I mean it's insane
it's absolutely and utterly insane
Daniel Rivera says urgently thank you
David urgently keep it up urgent Thank
You Josh flag says why have we stopped
talking about Trump's tiny infant hands
I was never talking about that so you'd
have to talk to someone who's been
following that story Paul says can you
say hello to my friend Henry hey Henry
great to see hunter Reed says Blake
Richardson from the band Between the
Buried and Me subbed to you yesterday
absolutely incredible drummer you should
check out sometime I would love to do
that thank you for the support minx
Johansson says sending love and hope
from Australia appreciate that
honey dog says for Michael Brooks yes
indeed check out my video the tragic
death of Michael Brooks we talked about
that extensively yesterday and there's
there's really a lot to say about it for
sure
Jacob ball thank you for the hundred
dollar super Chad I already dealt with
Jacob balls comment shot whoa what
happened there hold on Sean Bauman says
support the protesters in Portland they
need your help
Patrick Forney says Trump is a fascist
stay strong from Switzerland um yeah a
fascist I'm sure is what you meant
although that's an interest it's almost
like a foul gist
I wish Trump or a foul gist a follower
of doctor foul gee he's not he's not
sadly Myles Kaufman says if some
left-wing people are still never Biden
at this point despite covered and
protests is it worth convincing
them Biden is better at this point it's
always worth it you know there's
something very interesting I got a phone
call from a friend the other day and he
he actually may be watching and he told
me you know David there are some never
Biden people formerly never Biden people
who have taken Trump's reaction to the
George Floyd protests you know the
threats to send in the military now
actually sending the in the military it
has served as a reasonable credible
escape pod was the word that he used
which i think is perfect where there
were some of these early never Biden
people when Bernie loss that were saying
I mean I'm not doing Biden unless he
goes medicare-for-all or something which
we knew he wouldn't do and of course
it's gotten so bad that now Trump's
authoritarian reaction to the protests
has served as a reasonable enough escape
pod for them to say listen I still am
very unsure about Biden but I've got a
vote for him because of what Donald
Trump is doing I don't care how they get
to it as long as they get to it that's
really what matters well how did I even
get to that Oh miles a super chat right
very good
Chad lightning says how would you
respond to people who use larry elder
and thomas solo as basis for their
arguments and ignoring reality well
larry elder and thomas soul are two
dramatically different sort of people
you know they occupy different spaces
larry elder I've never found compelling
Thomas soul actually can make some
compelling economic arguments that I
don't find completely convincing but I
find important like for example Thomas
soul has some interesting takes on
affirmative action that they'd I don't
hear them and go wow everything I
believed is wrong but they're important
to at least understand and so I wouldn't
put them in the same category
Thomas soul I think is if you want to
sort of bone up on right-wing economics
I think Thomas soul is someone you
should look at larry elder i've never
found
any particular interest in William Van
Buskirk says hey David love your stuff
did you see Dave Rubin and Michael nose
did a book review of 1984 it's really
bad don't watch it yeah I saw that Dave
Rubin said that in 1984 what they needed
was a Trump yeah that that's what he
said
let me say it again Rubin said when he
read 1984 if he did I don't know I don't
know how you could actually read it and
come away with this idea but when you
read 1984 if they had had a Donald Trump
come in it would have fixed the
situation I feel like an idiot even
explaining to you what was said it's
crazy it's crazy yeah okay let's get off
of that topic let me thank a few other
people Pete Tatlock is new member number
seven today Daniel Kraus is new member
number eight
Oliver ba Strich is new member number
nine
Stephanie Peckinpah or Peckinpah is new
member number ten Luis Morales is new
member number eleven matzo ball soup
beautiful is number twelve
Shalom Racine Miller is new member
number thirteen Who am I missing here
Sondra Emmer is new member number
fourteen Kathy Warner is number fifteen
and amber Payette is number sixteen
today I know I'm missing some folks but
I will get back to thank yous you
haven't missed anything if you're just
joining us Donald Trump scheduled for a
press briefing nine minutes ago and the
room is relatively full and it seems
reasonable that we would see Donald
Trump arrive soon thanks to epic spawner
for subscribing for the seventh month in
a row on Twitch we do now have a hype
train going on twitch it yesterday we
only got to level one like we started
the hype train the hype train was
rolling out of the station and then it
was very very brutally interrupted so we
have four and a half minutes to get to
level two and we will soon see if we're
able to do that Wagyu Ettrick
says from the standpoint of covered will
we start seeing falsified numbers now
that the CDC is no longer covering cases
360noscope the like button yeah this is
a fair question so it's like now when we
look at these numbers let's update and
see where we are today forty-eight
thousand new cases today eight hundred
and forty five deaths
can we trust these numbers I don't know
I I genuinely have no idea there were
some states from which we probably
couldn't even trust the numbers before
and we had anecdotal allegations that
the numbers were not trustworthy but I
mean at this point I believe the numbers
are even less trustworthy and if that's
the case they're even worse than we're
being told um let's see here thanks to a
whole bunch of people over on twitch
getting us to level two of the hype
train just in Winchester says love your
show can you guide me on some people
talking about educational progressive
policies seems like a whole that I can't
find much talking about I'm not sure who
I would recommend on educational policy
I'd have to think about that that's not
I you know one of the things I try to do
is if I don't know much about a
particular area I don't pretend to know
I find no interest in doing that
education has never been my my strongest
suit so I'll have to think about that
brain Stu asks could self-deprecating
humor be a good strategy for dropping
Trump's guard and causing him to
tailspin in live events for example
chris wallace saying his son thinks he's
obnoxious they both laughed yeah I mean
listen I you try to try everything with
trumpet so I sort of take a try anything
mentality we are now on level three of a
hype train very exciting things
happening including a a cheer of 666
bits from false heurists which is crazy
waffles jirafa says i read eight rumpus
chat is it's a tire or the abyss I don't
believe the right really understand
satire remember on years ago I think it
was Fox News they decided to kind of
give their answer to The Daily Show with
Ben John
Stewart and they had a show called I
think the half-hour news hour
it was the most unfunny thing you could
imagine I mean just absolutely
ridiculous and I don't know that the
Wright really gets satire you know they
complained Oaks SNL and all these shows
they're all left-wing the right you know
the right doesn't understand satire just
look at interviews at a trump rally you
very quickly learned they don't
understand satire thanks to Viper bear
for gifting 20 subscriptions on Twitch
that pushes us to level four on the hype
train we have not been at level four no
we're at level five
wait note we've completed we have
completely completed we have one we did
it level four was absolutely destroyed
we are on a level five hype train and
have exceeded and gone above and beyond
that if you're on YouTube and you feel
like you're missing out you are but you
can join the party
by hitting that like button pops tackles
says here's my monthly contribution to
my favorite media source thank you David
you're sure you didn't mean to send
money to Michael Knowles right I hope
that that wasn't a mistake
cool drop says can you please speak up
away is this cool drop who calls in from
China because we have a caller named
cool drop who is an American guy I
believe teaching English in China I
don't know if this is the same person
can you please speak about the genocide
of afros from your home country of
Argentina I recently learned more about
what had is happening what is happening
I don't know about but yes Argentina has
a long racist history when it comes to
black folks and it is very ugly and I've
talked about it a little bit on the
program thanks to Marxist Leninist for
the subscription on Twitch as well as
Sid Baer was dead middle-aged metal
feminist cheap book and autofill my
username Wow Wow Marvin cotton says why
didn't Chris Wallace or yesterday's
briefing drilled Trump on Russian
bounties in Afghanistan yeah you know I
recently tweeted whatever happened with
those Russian bounties and I think it
would be great to push Trump on it I
think he'll just say he doesn't
anything about it III think that that's
the way it would go thanks to Roadeo for
subscribing as well as Alastair Cole
well Phil Roth says when voting for the
lesser of two evils
considering Biden's actions led to seven
Wars how is Trump worse than Biden has
more blood on his hands oh come on dad
that's absolutely ridiculous and I have
multiple clips about this and I have a
hard time even believing that that's a
serious question
it's a me malari oh says can a president
get fired yes we can fire him in
November
thanks to s BER for the subscription
Carl Smith says hi David I live in the
UK and got a membership via your website
last month to help support your channel
and the good work you were doing keep it
up thank you thanks to Gen gays o for
the Alpha subscription jamol Swift says
hey David hey homie did you see the new
Trump campaign ad depicting a police
officer being attacked by protesters
it's actually a video from 2014 a photo
of pro-democracy protests in Ukraine yes
I did see that I may talk about it
tomorrow in fact we are standing by for
a coronavirus press briefing from Donald
Trump
we are expecting ungodly sums of
propaganda I mean just ungodly we have
hit 500 percent level 5 hype train on
Twitch we have never done that before 30
seconds to go we have never reached 500
percent ever ever ever it's absolutely
stunning with looks like 20 seconds to
go unbelievable unbelievable 500% 540
percent it looks like 600 percent
oh my goodness things are going
completely crazy I don't even this this
feels like it has to be illegal right
like that can't be legal
jazz poor Garcia sends a super chat EB
Pryor says hey D do you know if there
are any rules stopping a former
president from joining the Supreme Court
there are none there are none Conner's
it Trower says favorite
or artists oh there's so many I couldn't
possibly name even a few but my musical
tastes are quite widespread the way I
like to describe it is mostly everything
other than country and heavy metal
country and heavy metal is not my thing
Sam Kareem says poster zucchinis on only
fans right I don't know if that's a
euphemism but I will potentially do I'll
post my zooks and cukes a little bit
later let me see here where did I leave
off okay friendly fire za says I think
that south var okay thank you for being
a consistent voice of reason in this new
era of excess information and
misinformation cheers from South Africa
Thank You Alberto Baron Yano says we
will miss you in Galicia this summer yes
I have family in northwestern Spain
beautiful area I was planning to be
there this summer but because of the
Trump virus as Nancy Pelosi is calling
it Trump Co v20 is another way to
describe it I am NOT going to be able to
be there such great seafood in Galicia
last time I was there I was in Santiago
I was in where else was i I was in a
state oh I drove over into Portugal and
went to Bordeaux it was just great it's
just such a great area totally different
totally totally different then you know
Barcelona and Madrid and the more
touristy areas as we call them hopefully
soon hopefully soon Alberto Pat Needham
says David what are your favourite
elements of medical um that's a really
good question I don't know coronavirus
vaccines are my favourite elements of
medical Jessica Russell chiming in a
Rallis says David can you reach out to
vouch for a debate slash interview okay
I can look into that not super familiar
name withheld says can you shout out my
cat Katina yes absolutely all beings are
welcome and cats are fine by the way oh
this is a funny thing a little while ago
I got a video of a Portuguese dog
watching my show now I don't mean a
Portuguese water dog the breed I mean
literally a Portuguese dog in Portugal
that whenever their owner watches the
show the dog perks up and is just
focused right in on me so if you have
video of your pet watching the David
Pakman show please get it to us
you can use the contact form on my
website because we love publicizing that
dogs in particular but we would accept
cats or someone I had a weasel that
liked the show but it felt a little bit
off-color so we didn't necessarily make
a huge deal out of a weasel liking the
show but certainly dogs and cats soldier
of science says I saw your chess match
yesterday your quote coach was pretty
amazing yes I have been in training with
levy Rosman Eric Rosen and Alexandre
boats as I've been posting the lessons
to YouTube after the fact and you can
find them and you know I think it's
gonna be a great tournament coming up
thanks that Tom Adams for signing up
Ninh Jack's says hi Dave a long time no
see do you think the secret police are
there to instigate a violent response so
Trump can refute the election yeah
that's part of it I mean it's I I had a
more detailed explanation at the top of
the stream but yeah that that's sort
that's the gist I would say of what it's
for norman sparks his thoughts on the
idea that kovat was actually designed
and whatever country did so was relying
on the stupidity of Americans to spread
it yeah I've seen no evidence of that
Travis Camacho says please say hi to my
best friend Gary we are both over this
clown in office this guy here and we
need him to go absolutely let's listen
in actually let's just switch over to
the White House feed now because when
Fox goes commercial I don't I don't
really like it will be 10 seconds behind
but I think it'll be worth it in the
Thanks that boy meets Minnie by the way
and net daddy for subscribing with
twitch prime appreciate that beast
casually as well also wife for the win
and cryptocat here is the mango menace
the tangerine terror Adolf Hitler let's
take a listen
hey Gough Whitlam sorry thank you very
much today my administration reached a
historic agreement with Pfizer to
produce and deliver 100 million doses of
their vaccine immediately following its
approval
hopefully the approval process will go
very quickly and we think we have a
winner there we also think we have other
companies written behind that are still
very well in the vaccines long ahead of
schedule as part of Operation warp speed
this agreement will also ensure that we
receive an additional 500 million doses
shortly thereafter this is another
crucial step in our effort to develop
manufacture and distribute a vaccine in
record-breaking time really a very small
fraction of the time based on previous
schedules no thanks the one thing the
FDA I want to thank everybody involved
it's been an incredible process Trump
has been not as discussed yesterday the
China virus poses the greatest threat to
our senior citizens as we all know the
median age for those who died from the
virus is 78 years old and nearly half of
the deaths have occurred among those
living in nursing homes or long-term
care facilities that's really something
in other words approximately half of the
fatalities have occurred among less than
1% of the US population so think of that
less than 1% half of the fatality less
than one so we know what to look for
from the beginning we have made it our
top priority to shelter our seniors he
said the same thing yesterday in early
March we announced guidelines suspending
all medically unnecessary visits to
nursing homes and prioritized resources
those facilities to notice from pride we
gave it a very strong priority FEMA has
sent shipments to many different
locations of protective equipment and
it's going directly to 15,400 Medicaid
and Medicare certified nursing homes
throughout the country today I'd like to
provide an update on the additional
actions we've been able to take and
they've been very constructive first
we're requiring increased testing of the
nursing home personnel in states where
you had the worst outbreak so all
personnel might be potentially
highest-level we're distributing 15,000
rapid point-of-care diagnostic devices
to support this effort these are the
tests where it takes five minutes - 15
minutes are very accurate they're very
good and we're sending them all over the
country and over 600 devices will be
also shipped this week - additional
facilities ii HHS will be distributing
an additional five billion dollars from
the provider relief fund to all nursing
homes nursing homes and higher risk
areas we'll be receiving more funding he
seems barely money can be used to
address critical needs including the
hiring of additional staff increasing
testing and providing technology support
so residents can connect their families
and they can connect to their families
they are having a tremendous time they
want to be with their loved ones they
can't do it so what we're doing is we're
working it so that we can connect have
them connect with their families if
they're not able to visit third we've
been identifying especially high-risk
nursing homes and sharing that
information with the governor's so that
the governor's and their staffs can take
appropriate action we're able to find
because of the testing programs and
other means were able to find certain
areas that are very high-risk the
governor's can then take action
additionally CMS CDC and the US Public
Health Service are providing enhanced
technical assistance and support
including visits to the highest risk
nursing homes
and that's their priority right now
nursing homes but the highest-risk
nursing homes CMS and CDC are
implementing a national training program
focused on infection control for those
nursing homes that need it most and we
have them surveyed and we have them
mostly pinpointed over the past few
months we've created a surveillance
system to detect outbreaks and currently
99% of all nursing homes are reporting
directly to it so we have it's detecting
anything because we're a nursing home
has three or more cases we alert this
state and make sure that it responds
very quickly we check on it make sure
they respond very quickly I want to send
a message of support and hope to every
senior citizen who has been dealing with
the struggle of isolation and what
should be the golden years of your life
we will get to the other end of that
tunnel very quickly we hope the life
that youth from starting to shine we
will get there very quickly but we send
our love we send a message of love very
important we're with you all the way as
far as the outbreak in the Sunbelt I
said yesterday we continue to vigorously
combat the rise of cases in the south
and southwest and the West we're closely
monitoring and aggressively acting to
control the infection in Texas Arizona
California Florida Arizona is starting
to come down I've done a very good job
they're all doing a good job they're
very talented people incredible talent
there are likely a number of causes for
the spike in infections yes we know
cases started to rise among young
Americans shortly after demonstrations
which you know very well about which
presumably triggered a broader
relaxation of mitigation efforts
nationwide and of substantial increase
in travel also was a cause increased
gathering on holidays such as Memorial
Day as well as young people closely
congregating at bars and probably other
places maybe beaches four or five
different lists have been logical for
months ago
listed on the guide likely also
contributed were
also sharing a 2,000 mile border with
Mexico as we know very well in cases of
surging in Mexico unfortunately with the
President and so remember he's been
saying no one's coming over the border
because the border so strong now he
seems to be again going back to you know
some of those southern states having
trouble because of that border with
Mexico 257 miles of newly constructed
wall along the southern border has had a
great positive impact on people coming
in and we have record low numbers of
people coming in illegally that's helped
greatly not only meant for a different
purpose but it worked out very well for
what we're doing right now and for the
pandemic nationwide beyond the outbreak
in several states cases remain low and
very stable nineteen states a positive
test rates of less than five percent
eight states have positive test rates of
less than two percent our nationwide
positive test rate is beginning to
decline and is currently at eight point
eight percent compared to over 16
percent at its peak in April it's coming
down it's coming down fairly rapidly
today we surpassed first time we
surpassed 50 million tests that's far
more for the first any country in the
world in the asset again tomorrow is
second we believe we think one point
four billion people that's about 12
million tests we have 50 million tests
we're working with every state to ensure
the supply of remedy severe for early
case intervention and steroid treatment
and various other treatments for those
that are seriously ill we're working
very closely with hospitals doctors and
nursing homes everybody the remedy
severe has proven to be terrific our
case fatality rate continues to decline
and we want to push this rate even lower
the therapeutic research continues daily
or new and very promising treatments
including antibody treatments and the
use of blood thinners and steroids a lot
of different things are happening and a
lot of things are coming out that
we wouldn't have known number of months
ago we're doing tremendously well on
therapeutic research and tremendously
well on the vaccines and frankly
therapeutically or maybe a word even
beyond that word is cure would be the
best of all and we'll see what happens
but that would be great if we could go
into the hospital and just cure people
and we're at a position we're actually
able to to a certain extent with what we
have right now and we think in a very
short period of time we'll be able to do
that our strategy is to shelter the
highest risk Americans what are allowing
younger and healthier citizens to return
to work or school while being careful
and very vigilant wear a mask
socially distance and repeatedly wash
your hands practice very very good
sanitary means you have to do this you
have to just you have to look at it
differently wash your hands often I'm
finding more and more people are saying
wash your hands so wash your hands we
want young Americans to avoid pact bars
and other crowded into our gatherings
and we're all in this together just say
they should be closer as Americans we're
going to get this complete we're going
to do it properly we've been doing it
properly sections of the country come up
that we didn't anticipate for instance
Florida Texas and such Florida was a
real shock we're working with very
talented people very brilliant people
and it's all going to work out and it is
working out so with that I'll take a few
questions please here we go
she was to the surge of federal agents
to various cities remember of
psychologists and moments ago that
you're doing this to divert attention
from your
a virus you are only targeting you are
only targeting cities Democrats it's
just a political stock
Nastia the cities unfortunately that are
in trouble a role run by Democrats you
have CDs Olympia run by down on cities
like Chicago and so many others that we
just had a news conference said
unfortunately that's the way it is I
mean that's the facts when you look at
Chicago and you look at the job
mayor Lightfoot sent me a letter
yesterday and I think in their own way
they want us to go and there'll be a
time when they're gonna want us to go
and fall do not write now we're sending
extra people to help we're arresting a
lot of people that have been very bad as
far as the coronavirus as you say I
think we've done some amazing things and
I think you'll probably see them we are
one of the worst there are statistics to
other countries and if you look at death
rates etc you're going to see and
especially into the future with what's
happening you're gonna see some very
very we have the tenth class at numbers
how the united states mr. president do
you plan to do a national strategy to
help schools reopen and reopen say oh
yeah guarding the children in your
family your son your grandchildren are
you comfortable do you plan to have them
back in person in school yes I am
comfortable with it and we do have a
national strategy but as you know
ultimately routers are the governors of
the states I think most governors many
governors want these schools to open I
would like to see the schools open
especially when you see statistics like
this we have great statistics and on
young people and on safety so we would
like to see schools open we want to see
the economy open we just had a report
literally as I walk in that we set an
all-time record on housing price
increases up I think they said 21
percent which is a record that's never
happened before that's why the values
are up 2,100 but it's been how is that
even remotely
produced the job numbers will be coming
out shortly meaning over the next 21 so
I think I see continuation my last two
months the Lester ones have been
incredible so I think we're gonna have a
great economy you can have a fantastic
next year I think you're gonna have a
very good third quarter actually we're
the third quarter numbers come out
interestingly they'll be announced just
before the election they'll be announced
around November first so yeah I would
like to see the schools open open a
hundred percent and open Y safely we'll
do it carefully but when you look at
this distance the statistics I just read
having struggling with that where our
children and and safety and they're very
impressive they have very strong immune
systems the children who go to school
then go back to home there with some
live with their grandparents there's
there's a real risk would you understand
them so they do say that they don't
transmit very easily and a lot of people
are saying they don't transport we're
looking at that was stunning John very
hard Oh God there we go the subject that
they don't bring it home with them now
they don't catch it easily they don't
bring it home easily and if they do
catch it they get better fast we're
looking at that fact that is a fabulous
Broncos young we will be reporting about
that over the next week please at least
three governor's today came
with new orders on mass performance is
that something you wish all the
governors would do well a lot of the
governor's they have different
requirements some of the governor's are
very strong and masks others are strong
I think it's really going to ultimately
be up to them we've given them the facts
we've given a moment ago they have their
own facts some are strong in masks and
as you know some aren't some are strong
mass ballpark but I think well I think
all is suggesting if you want to wear a
mask you wear everybody have you worn
heroin and I think when I'm in certain
settings like hospitals and various or
when I'm close when you know when you
can't socially distance I believe in it
let's see Pierre pointed out he always
has it now I have and if you know when
certain in certain instances I think you
really I think you want to travel with a
mess there are instances where you
really can use it I would believe it
would be it's funny it's like he has no
idea that the airline's mandate the mask
you would really want to travel with it
longer today it of course doesn't apply
to federal properties but would you
encourage federal properties and
including the White House complex to
follow the order we're gonna make a
decision over the next 24 hours we'll
let you know what that decision is
the possibility of extending short-term
unemployment insurance to will he call
on Katelyn Collins he's already avoiding
her you can tell from expiring well I
think a lot of politicians are
discussing that Republicans Democrats
and right now a lot of my
representatives are on the hill they're
discussing cares act or phase four
whatever you want to call it and I think
ultimately something good will come out
of it the economy is starting to really
come back strongly when you look at the
numbers even with the fact that like
California is still closed up in many
big states I think the numbers are even
more impressive considering that some
states like California big California is
kind of to open a pretty well shutdown
so we expect to have something over a
period of time over the appropriate
period of time these two questions are
with Andrew Feinberg and JC Buell one is
today said you're sending federal law
enforcement officers to run cities run
by extreme politicians that's the word
you used which who happened to be all
Democrats who supported black lives
matter protest no I said Democrat
politicians and these are the cities
where you have the problem if you look
at Chicago if you look at Detroit if you
look I mean look around any of these
cities where we have the problems and
we're sending them help but we're really
waiting for them to call for the big
help for the big numbers for the large
numbers of people that we have ready
willing and able you look at Chicago
where 14 people were shot yesterday
where over the weekend many people died
and many people were shot and over the
last month they're setting record
numbers we are waiting for the mayor
respectfully and other mayors and
governors to call us we are ready
willing and able to go in there with
great force now we also have people that
are going in and arresting drug dealers
arresting some of the shooters that are
doing the shooting we know who they are
we're working with police forces and
even though in some cases they're told
don't work with the federal government
or suppose they're doing have great
respect for the federal government what
we do but we're ready willing and able
to go into these cities that are just
being decimated with shooting and we're
going to help please
I have a question on crime but first I
don't think we've really got an
explanation yesterday on why that health
experts are no longer joining you at
these briefings because they're briefing
me I'm meeting them I just spoke to dr.
pouchy dr. Burks is right outside he
keeps her right out of everything they
know as of as of this point in time and
I'm giving the information to you and I
think it's probably a very concise way
of doing it it seems to be working out
very well
okay very much they're very much
involved they're very much what the
relationships are all very good
everybody's like that the relationships
that we have with the doctors with
everybody working on the virus has been
I think extraordinary Kaylee's here and
I think you would say the same thing you
work with them you'll say whatever you
want so why is that the president's
fault and then but it's not your fault
Wow Chicago only disaster the mayor is
saying don't come in the mayor is
telling us not to come in at some point
we can void that if we have to but we
and we may have to it's up because it's
out of control
I assume she's saying that for political
reasons I think it's negative political
not Ann Ann's a friend she's a Democrat
I'm gonna be nice she's a Democrat she's
making a big mistake people are dying in
Chicago and other cities and we can
solve the problem they have to ask us
but we can solve the problem 2016 was
invited in and he did a poor job
President Obama could have gone into
Chicago he could have solved the problem
and he did so in our case we can cite
the problem very easily we're equipped
with the best equipment the best people
and you see what we're doing I mean
Portland was coming down it was busting
at the seams and we went in and
protected all the federal buildings
those federal buildings had totally
protected it was the thing we had to do
that in Portland's a very different
place in Chicago but Chicago should be
following us and so should Philadelphia
and Detroit and others to go in and
really help them because when you're
losing many people a weekend many many
people you see this
as I do when you losing these people
they should call us and they should say
come on in and it's incredible to me but
they're not doing it at some point they
will at some point we may have no other
choice but to go and Jeff are you
looking at closing further Chinese
embassies in the United States and did
you ask ambassador Woody Johnson to
bring the British Open to your third
Barry or Turnberry property in stock no
I never spoke to Woody Johnson about
that about Turnberry
turbos a highly respected course as you
know one of the best in the world and I
read I read a story about it today and I
had never read all authorities don't
think God no as far as closing
additional embassies it's always
possible you see what's going on we
thought there was a fire in the one that
we did close and everybody said there's
a fire there's a fire and I guess they
were burning documents or burning papers
and I wonder what that's all about would
you like to respond to Joe Biden who
today described you you might have heard
that as the first racist to be
interesting because we did criminal
justice reform we've passed criminal
justice reform something great Obama and
Biden were unable to do we did
opportunity cities we did the greatest
if if you look at what we've done with
Opportunity Zones and nobody's ever even
thought of a plan like that nobody even
thought about prior to the china plague
coming in floating in coming into our
country and really doing terrible things
all over the world doing terrible things
we had the best african-american
Hispanic American asian-american almost
every group was the best for
unemployment the unemployment numbers
were the best when you look at
employment you look at opportunities
owns and maybe most importantly owned
you look at criminal justice reform you
look at prison reform I've done things
that nobody else and I've said this and
I say it openly and not a lot of people
dispute it I've done more for black
Americans than anybody with the possible
exception
of Abraham Lincoln there you go nobody
has even been close thank you very much
everybody
[Music]
who's ghilane Maxwell question is oh my
god hey by the way do you guys want to
do a little G lane Maxwell thing cuz
I've got a little something prepared for
that this is for tomorrow's show I'll
show it to you guys if you're headed out
please do remember if you're watching on
Twitch just hit the follow button if
you're watching on YouTube please hit
that subscribe button it's free you'll
be notified of my next stream which I
very much appreciate but let me do just
a little G lane Maxwell stuff for you
okay check this out
yesterday Trump was asked about ghilane
Maxwell and here's what he had to say
okay take a listen to this it spends by
the time you get it back it's three or
four days if they do an efficient job
we're trying to get the testing about
this lane Maxwell is in precisly
and so a lot of people want to know
she's going to turn in powerful people
and I know you talked in the past about
Prince Andrew and so you criticize Bill
Clinton's behavior I'm wondering do you
feel free to turn into powerful men how
do you see that working out I don't know
I haven't really been following it too
much I just wish it well frankly okay so
I wished her well is weird but there's
something else I want to show you I've
met her numerous times over the years
especially since I lived in Palm Beach
and I guess they lived in Palm Beach but
I wish her well whatever it is I don't
know the situation with Prince Andrew
just don't know not aware of it don't
know the situation with Prince Andrew
let me show you guys a little something
okay this is an inner not this there's a
commercial but this is an interview from
2015 listen to what Trump says
unprovoked about Jeffrey Epstein and
Andrew okay take a look
that was tough stuff that was nasty you
think was over-the-line I don't know
because I don't know her but it was
nasty you raised the question of Jeffrey
Epstein in your remarks about friend
annuity he's got a problem I don't think
a problem I don't know but that Island
was really a cesspool there's no
question about it just yes Prince Andrew
he'll tell you about it huh Oh
interesting wait a second just ask if
you want to know the guy to ask would be
print when wait a sec one of the
homeowners I mean but I could just want
you to said he doesn't know anything
about Prince Andres sure sounded pretty
certain about the Prince Andrew
connection back in 2015 so listen
there's two possibilities neither of
them is good either Trump was lying
yesterday when he says he doesn't know
anything about Prince Andrew in
connection with Epstein or his brain
really is mush and you know there are
people around the White House who
anecdotally have said Trump doesn't
remember anything and he's having a
memory issue so I don't know which of
the two it is it neither is good neither
is good I think is the absolutely a
clear thing at this point that we should
that that that we should be
understanding so I'm gonna have more
coverage of that tomorrow and I know
it's also very weird to be asked what do
you think about this serial accused
child sex trafficker and go well I wish
her well
I really wish her well that's the big
thing that is absolutely crazy
and we're going to be talking about that
tomorrow as well certainly so that's
going to do it for me let's um let's
raid Hasan if we are over on twitch
we've not done a raid of Hasan for a
very very long time we will otherwise
just be rapping on all of our other a
very explosive platforms and I may be
back tomorrow remember on the way out
grab those free youtube subscriptions
it's just the subscribe button that's
all it is make sure you're following
over on Twitch and I will see all of you
very very soon
you